- Le mouvement pour le droit
s s femmes est en plein
effervescence dans
les années 60. elle vient
notamment d'obtenir le droit
universel à la contraception.Mat
n'est pas encore un droit
reconnu pour toutes les
américaines. L'histoire
légale de Roe contre Wade,
elle, commence au Texas en 1970.
Norma McCorvey, 22 ans, veut
se faire avorter, mais son État
le permet seulement si la vie
de la femme est en danger,
ce qui n'est pas son cas.
Ses avocates contestent alors
la constitutionnalité de
cette loi antiavortement et
poursuivent l'État du Texas.
Jane Roe, c'est le pseudonyme
choisi pour préserver
l'anonymat de leur cliente.
Henry Wade est le procureur
de Dallas. Norma McCorvey
a le temps d'accoucher
de son enfant et de le faire
adopter avant que sa cause se
retrouve devant la Cour suprême.
Le 22 janvier 1973...
Sept juges contre deux tranchent
en faveur d'une interprétation
de la Constitution où le droit
à la vie privée d'une femme qui
souhaite se faire avorter prime
sur les lois des états.
dans sa décision la cour balise
toutefois l'intervention elle
est accessible pour toutes
pendant le premier trimestre...
après son accès peut être
restreint si l'avortement est
jugé dangereux pour la femme.
l'intervention peut être
interdite seulement la toute fin
de la grossesse.
Peu de temps après, Norma
McCorvey dévoile son identité.
Dans les années 90, elle crée
la surprise.
(applaudissements)
Elle trouve son salut dans
la religion et joint les rangs
du mouvement antiavortement.
Revirement sur son lit de mort,
la femme alors âgée de 69 ans
dit avoir été payée pour militer
contre l'avortement.
Norma McCorvey meurt en 2017.
Et cinq ans plus tard,
la cause qui porte son nom
résonne encore.
Ici Pasquale Harrison-Julien,
Radio-Canada, Montr